أعني أنه بالنظر إلى التقدم
المعتاد للمرض ، ما الذي كنت تبحث
عنه في الأيام القليلة المقبلة ،
نعم ، لقد تم ذكر مثل هذا ، هذا في
الواقع
عادة ما يكون بطيئًا ، لذلك لا
نتوقع الكثير في الأسبوع الأول
وغالبًا ما نقوم بذلك  رؤية المرضى في وقت مبكر
من مسار مرضهم وسنقول
إننا نرسلك إلى المنزل ليس لأننا
نقول أنك خرجت من الغابة ولكن
لأنه لا يوجد شيء تفعله من
أجلك الآن
لأن لديك أعراض خفيفة من  نزلة برد
أو نوع من الأنفلونزا
ثم ننبه الجميع
إلى أنه من الممكن أن يأخذوا
منعطفًا مفاجئًا إلى الأسوأ بعد مرور سبعة إلى عشرة أيام من المرض وأن يكونوا على
أهبة الاستعداد لتوخي الحذر الشديد
حيال ذلك
والعودة إلى  المستشفى إذا كانت
الأمور ستزداد حدة ورأينا بالطبع
أن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بوريس
جونسون
أم أصيب بمرض شديد أه حوالي
تسعة أيام من المرض الذي كان
نوعًا من النمط الكلاسيكي للطمع
، نعم ، ويمكن أن يضرب بشدة لاحقًا ،
أعني واحدًا آخر  الشيء الذي أردت أن أسأله منا
نحن نعلم من
الآخرين وقد ذكرت آه مخطط القلب
واختبارات أخرى أنه قد تم إعطاؤه من
الآخرين الذين تعافوا
من العدوى الأولية ، يمكن أن يكون هناك
آثار دائمة أه
تندب الرئة والمشاكل العصبية وما إلى
ذلك يمكن أن
تكون هذه الأشياء مخاطرة للرئيس نعم
بالتأكيد أعني أنه إذا
استمر في الإصابة بمرض فيروس كورونا الشديد
الذي يمكن أن يؤثر على كل عضو في جسمك
والمرضى الذين
يعانون من المرض الشديد والموجودون
في المستشفى لفترة طويلة
من الزمن أو يحتاجون إلى رعاية العناية المركزة
أعني أن دورة المرض الخاصة بهم يمكن أن تستمر
لعدة أسابيع حتى أشهر ،
أعني أننا ما زلنا نتعلم عن
المرضى الذين لم
يتعافوا بعد عدة أشهر من مرضهم
،
ولكن حتى المرضى الذين يعانون من مرض أكثر اعتدالًا ،
فإن
هذا لا يشبه فقط الأنفلونزا
أصدقائي الذين عانوا منه على
الرغم من أنهم بقوا في المنزل ولم يكن عليهم
الذهاب إلى المستشفى ،
لقد أوقعهم حقًا على
الأرض ووصفوا ذلك حقًا.  هو
تعب يكسر العظام سمعته
مقارنة
بالأمراض الأخرى لحمى الضنك وحتى
الإيبولا وقد قال الناس إنه أصابني
بالإحباط كما لم يحدث لمرض آخر
وكان هناك
تعافي طويل حتى للأشخاص الذين
لم يكونوا حرجين  مريض لذلك
أنا أتوقع أن دراسته سوف تتناسب جيدًا
مع
ما تعرفه في الشهر المقبل